attacks on health care which have
resulted in 101 days of health workers
and patients
the war is exacerbating Health needs
including for mental health and
psychosocial support
Rehabilitation treatment for diseases
like chronic diseases and others such as
cancer HIV and tuberculosis and
vaccinations for measles polio and
pneumonia and covid
these gaps are a risk to health today
and for the future
who is working closely with Partners in
Ukraine and has reached 8.4 million
people with health interventions
who has delivered nearly 300 metric tons
of life-saving medical supplies
including ambulances generators
medicines for chronic diseases and
Trauma and surgery emergency supplies to
Ukraine since the start of the conflict
thank you
to support our work who has appealed for
240 million years dollars to reach
11.4 million people withheld assistance
in Ukraine and refugees receiving
countries
the conflict is affecting Health not
just in Ukraine but around the world
with millions of people impacted by
spiking food prices especially in
low-income countries
as always
we need help for peace and peace for
health
finally on covid-19
new research adds to the weight of
evidence about the benefits of
vaccination and boosting
as well as dramatically reducing the
chances of severe disease and death
the research reinforces that vaccination
and boosting also reduce the likelihood
of patients with coveted 19 from having
heart attack or stroke
I emphasize these findings because it
underlines once again why governments
should continue to vaccinate and boost
their populations especially the most
at-risk groups including older people
and health workers
it's also critical that governments
maintain and strengthen surveillance and
sequencing so that the virus evolves
vaccines Therapeutics and Diagnostics
can be evaluated and updated quickly as
needed
this week whs technical Advisory Group
for covid-19 vaccine composition
emphasized the need for continued
surveillance
to guide the composition of vaccines and
to assess their effectiveness
while the world is collectively in a
better position than it was three years
ago this virus should not be
underestimated
it's therefore important to invest in
research in order to develop vaccines
that can provide broader protection
and also reduce transmission
earthquakes
conflict and the ongoing impact of the
covid-19 pandemic all reinforce the
fragility the world faces and the need
to strengthen our Collective differences
against Health emergencies
this week who member states are hosting
discussions on amendments to the
international Health regulations
next week countries will begin
negotiations on a zero draft of the new
pandemic Accord
these discussions will be crucial for
building a more effective Health
security architecture for the future
grounded in international law equity and
the fundamental right to health for all
people
at the Munich security conference last
Friday
I said that right now the world remains
unprepared for another pandemic
while leaders have many other crises to
deal with attention on future epidemic
and pandemic threats must remain or we
will pay a heavy price
no crisis happens in isolation
in a world of converging and overlapping
crisis we need a shared coherent and
Equitable Global approach to Shared
Global Health threats Christian back to
you
thank you very much Dr Terrace with this
we open the floor with questions from
the media and let me remind you again to
get into the queue to ask questions
please press the raise your hand icon on
your screen and then unmute yourself
when it's time to go
um first question goes to Musa ASI from
Almighty in TV Musa please unmute
yourself
yes very well
foreign
[Music]
ly catch the beginning because we didn't
have time enough for the interpretation
but uh yes exactly but we go to Rick
Brennan um who's the Regional Emergency
director in the Eastern Mediterranean
region and he's joining us from
uh thanks Christian and thank you for
the question a great question uh who is
moving very rapidly right now together
with our partners to take advantage of
this pause in the sanctions
um we have already started ordering
equipment and supplies
um and we are working with un Partners
on a collective approach to uh to take
advantage of of the pause
um you're you're absolutely right we not
only need medicines and consumables and
vaccines we need vital equipment like
x-ray machines surgical equipment and so
on so at the same time we are doing a
more detailed assessment of those needs
and we'll be moving very very rapidly to
do the procurement again capitalizing on
this important opportunity that we have
so you know I'm confident that things
are moving in the right directions we've
already had four uh airlifts Planes full
of supplies and equipment come into
serious and the since the start of the
since the earthquake and we will be
moving into a situation where we'll be
able to bring in that that heavy
equipment in the weeks and months ahead
thank you
thank you very much understand Dr
Kathy's Smallwood uh who's the
earthquake incident manager for Europe
um can join
thanks very much just to add of course
that um uh undercovered we found it very
difficult to get laboratory supplies
um in Syria and both both directions and
we'll be working really to uh to use
this opportunity as the Regional
Emergency director said thank you
thank you very much both with this we go
to the next question that goes to Erin
parata from Fortune Aaron please go
ahead and mute
my question was addressed thank you so
much
thank you very much lucky today next
question goes to Simon atiba from
today's news Africa Simon please go
ahead
yes thank you for taking my question
Christian this is Simon Activa with
Today News Africa in
in Florida
um I I wanted to have an update on the
the marble disease in Equatorial kidney
Cameroon and
the neighboring countries thank you
thank you very much Simon and Flora and
we'll go to Dr Abdi Mahmoud
um for this please thanks Simon and I
just would like to take this opportunity
to thank the minister of health of the
three countries for the rapid deployment
of teams and then for strengthening the
basic investigation and Healthcare as we
speak right now we have currently nine
deaths including the one confirmed and
particularly there is a digital
investigation with teams from who
headquarter the regional office and with
the minister of Health are there so we
don't have more update because there are
several cases have been suspected
confirmed cases probable cases so we'll
be waiting to get that detailed outbreak
response
from the field team because it a lot of
the death happened before this was
declared so it'll be a lot of
retrospective investigation and detailed
investigation on that what's more
important right now is the the Readiness
in the neighboring countries The
Cameroon and Gabon both moved in a rapid
action and have strengthened the
Readiness and particular surveillance
but and more importantly in the
community surveillance at who we're
working very closely just yesterday the
executive director and the DG have
released half a million if we start the
initial plan and then to enhance further
the response but coming back outbreak
start and then in the community that the
community engagement and bringing this
community on our side will be very very
much appropriate and the initial step as
we have learned and as we from the
lesson in Uganda integrating research is
very key into this as we don't have
right now proven and approved
countermeasures and we've been
communicating with Ministry of Health to
accelerate the research into this
response
thank you very much and Dr Mahmoud and
next question goes to belisa godinya
from W magazine in Portugal
hello everybody yes all good
I'm belizzi Gooding from W magazine
based in Lisbon Portugal my question is
related to Global Health prevention the
recent problem of the lack of dialogue
in successful negotiations for peace
between Ukraine and Russia Russia
and the breaking of the new Star treaty
with the United States makes it urgent
to have correct information about the
effects of atomic energy weapons on
human health for the health of all
living beings and the health of the
planet can who help
clarify this matter thanks
thank you very much we'll start with Dr
Michael
I think everyone was aware of the
devastating effect of uh nuclear weapons
and and radiation can have on people who
are not properly protected so who
remains very concerned uh about uh
radiologic safety in all settings and
especially in Ukraine given the the war
um we support our colleagues in the iaea
who are the responsible Agency for this
we're a part of a a medical emergency
response Network for with with ieeea we
continue to work with the the Ukrainian
authorities to ensure that we've got
adequate training of of of health
workers on the Ukrainian side
um but uh obviously from what you
mentioned uh the the issues here are not
about health the impact will be on
health but this is not in itself a
health issue this is obviously a very
very political issue in the middle of a
very devastating War so we would uh call
on on all sides in in in in the conflict
to ensure that radio sites where
radiologic material is present to be
protected and be avoid it in any form or
shape in this conflict and that just
Echoes the calls where our colleagues in
the iea over many months but we do have
a team working on this we are ready to
support and work with other agencies
should anything happen and we've been
working with with Ukrainian Authorities
on that diligently over the last number
of months but this is a real
um issue and everyone needs to be
exceptionally careful and and quite
frankly I'm I'm not as concerned about
the intentional use of anything I'm more
concerned about accidents and I'm more
concerned about the fact that this
nuclear plants continue to be run
um
in a very
um in a manner that requires a lot of
courage and a lot of commitment from a
very small number of staff and we just
want to make sure that everyone remains
safe and we do commend those workers
will continue to work to keep those
plans safe particularly in Ukraine
thank you much Dr Ryan next question
goes to
Miriam nadaf from nature magazine Miriam
please go ahead and unmute
hello
if wh have already all planned to supply
these semi besieged Northwest region of
Syria with basic medical supplies such
as antibiotics we are concerned of
spread of infections both the earthquake
and as we all know three Crossing points
are now open on this here in Turkish
border but before the earthquake there
were only 66 hospitals savings 4.5
million people in the northwest of Syria
and doctors on the ground have
um told us that most hospitals have run
out of antibiotics on day three after
the earthquake and even with simple
injuries most patients would need
antibiotics or some sort of painkiller
so I'd just like to know if there are
any plans if this has happened already
or there are any new plans to do that as
soon as possible to respond to the
present needs of the hospitals and
medical facilities there specific
quickly supplies of basic
medicine like antibiotics and
painkillers thank you
thank you very much Miriam I understand
we have a bit of an audio problem to our
regional colleagues because this would
be perfect for Dr Rick Brennan the
Regional Emergency director in the
Eastern Mediterranean region which is
trying to submit the the basic ideas of
your questions to him and hoping that
they can understand us and hear us and
then can answer that question
um otherwise it's it's a good idea
actually we start here in the room with
Dr Adelaide Martian she's the health
operations lead for the earthquake
response and if we get the the line back
then we'll go back to Dr Rick Brennan
thank you
yes thank you very much for the question
um as you know we have been uh
operational
um in doing cross-border
um services and humanitarian assistance
for the last 10 to 12 years so we had an
established pipeline of uh supplies
medicines and Technical Services into
Northwest Syria prior to the earthquake
which has now been scaled up and thank
you for referring to essential medicines
clearly we have scaled up the supply to
those including uh antibiotics
painkillers that you have highlighted
but also trauma supplies and we're
looking now into increasing uh also the
proportion of NCD meaning
non-communicable disease men distance
that are growing more and more important
in in the needs
as far as we receive
um from from the communities and from
the health facilities that the partners
are supplying with who we are constantly
working
and as DG has mentioned uh 3 000 tons of
supplies have already been delivered on
the ground throughout the operation
including of course and with the key
focus on Northwest Syria
back over to you thank you very much
Dr Smallwood would like to add I'll jump
yeah so we'll start with Dr Catherine
Smallwood from the earthquake incident
manager for the European region go ahead
yeah I just want to say that we were
I've been in Syria um twice over the
past week and my colleague uh Rick
Brennan and Gerald brookens shelb online
were in Syria yesterday and they can
speak for their views what was clear to
us is that in the immediate days after
the earthquake all of the Distribution
Systems were actually disrupted because
our partners on the ground and the
healthcare workers on the ground were
immediately involved themselves in the
search and rescue operations since then
of course as um my colleague adolheit
has said we've been able to really
re-establish our distribution channels
within the country and we've moved over
139 new uh tons of medical supplies
including antibiotics as you mentioned
and other surgical supplies to affected
areas
um perhaps uh Dr Brennan and Dr reckon
shop can also
um give their views on what they've saw
yesterday
um yeah just to add to that I think
we've been working with the 140 one ngos
within the health cluster we really like
to pay tribute to those non-governmental
organizations who operate all across
Northwestern Syria who we've been
providing more than 50 percent of the
medical supplies into Northwest Syria
for as as Adelaide said for over a
decade we're very pleased to welcome the
media attention back to this forgotten
crisis our staff our ngos and our Focus
has been entirely on protecting the
lives of over 2.7 million people called
it the most desperate struggle for Life
long before this earthquake happened
um and I would just like to to to to to
to recognize that in the aftermath of
any major crisis there are frustrations
there's never the supplies the supply
chains are disrupted there may be breaks
in supply chain our job is to fix that
our job is to re-engage with the ngos
fix those Supply chains that's why our
staff have been over there that's why we
continue to work but I I think it's a
false premise to present a view that
nothing was happening in advance the
earthquake happened there were no
supplies we have been there for a decade
we will be there through this earthquake
and we will be there until the suffering
of these people is ended not just the
suffering caused by the earthquake but
the suffering caused by this
insufferable War
thank you very much Dr Ryan and all
um I have right now one more question in
the queue so that's your chance actually
to put your hand up because I saw two
hands went down it looks like many had
the same question today and they were
all answered which is great in some way
um so for now my uh the last question
goes to Mega
K if I get that right from Health policy
watch in Geneva Mega please go ahead
thank you Christian am I Audible
yes please okay thanks
um so there was a recent piece um on a
publication based on a comprehensive
analysis of studies that uh said that
masks were not effective in
um addressing the pandemic and other
respiratory illnesses I just wanted to
know what the who's position on that is
right now thank you so much
thank you very much Mega to change of
topic and understand we have Dr Maria
van kirkov online so Maria if you could
take that yes thanks Chris so thanks
thanks for the question
um so we continue to advise um the use
of masks as part of a comprehensive
strategy to reduce transmission of of
covet 19. the virus is circulating
pretty much unchecked around the world
at the moment and masks the appropriate
use of masks over your nose and mouth
are one of the ways in which we can
reduce the spread and we can prevent
infection we can prevent transmission
there was a systematic review that was
published that was looking at randomized
controlled trials but as an organization
we continue to look at all available
evidence that is provided to us that is
published through this pandemic into the
fourth year of this pandemic as well as
looking at other studies of other
respiratory diseases including flu but
also looking at influenza like illness
acute respiratory infections severe
acute respiratory infections and again I
reiterate that the use of masks continue
to be part of our strategy to reduce the
spread one of the ways we have a
strategy energy that is out there that
is based on vaccinations it's based on
distancing as much as possible as much
as reasonable as we go about and live
our lives wearing a well-fitting masks
when we're around others and
particularly on public transportation
and certainly among health workers the
use of masks and respirators as well as
other personal protective equipment
remain absolutely essential to protect
our front line workers who are providing
Optimal Care to patients around the
world so we will continue to update our
recommendations for health workers as
well as for people in the communities to
do what they can to live their lives as
covid continues to circulate but again
masks remains one of the recommendations
that we have because we know that they
are effective at preventing some of the
transmission they're not perfect that's
why we have a comprehensive strategy a
layered approach of many different types
of interventions so thanks for that
question
okay thank you very much Maria
um I see One Last Hand which we're gonna
take now and that's Jamie Keaton from
the Associated Press Jamie please go
ahead
thank you Christian
um just going back to the Northwest
Syria situation and um after Mike's uh
strong uh uh reminder that who has been
getting Aid into to Syria for for some
time
um what this I guess this is for Dr
Brennan if you can hear me
um is what concerns do you have about
people in need in Northwestern Syria
that may not be getting the aid in other
words what
difficulties are you aware of about the
distribution once the aid gets across
the border and actually getting once
it's inside uh Northwest Syria whether
it's actually being distributed because
we've had concerns from the white
helmets as you may know about them not
being involved or receiving any
unrelated Aid thank you so much
thanks Jamie who are coming back to this
but I'll I'll give back over to gazian
tip and to our colleagues there maybe
start with Dr Rick Brennan
um if you're still online to emergency
director for the Eastern Mediterranean
Rick yeah thanks thanks Christian and
again thanks for the question uh you
know perhaps building on what Mike had
said earlier
um you know Gerald and I went into
Northwest Syria yesterday we covered
quite a bit of territory uh visited some
of the worst impacted Villages and towns
from the earthquake and what was clearly
visible to us uh in addition to the
immediate impact of this crisis was we
were visiting communities and health
facilities that had suffered the
deterioration of 10 to 12 years of
conflict recurrent displacement
um and major economic decline already
around 90 of the population was living
below the poverty line and this the
other quick has just been another
amazingly difficult compounding insult
Mike talked about uh the many needs
we've also that these people have also
gone through the covert pandemic and
ongoing cholera outbreak and on and on
and on so the health system is
deteriorated remarkably uh in in that
context
um certainly health facilities are are
under resourced so what what are the
priority needs at the moment
um I think we're in the early recovery
phase
um there are still persistent trauma
needs but most of the acute trauma needs
have been addressed
um there are needs for just basic
Essential Health Services at Primary
Care level but also at hospital level
my colleague Adel Hyde mashang talked
about not only the the basic health kids
at Primary Care level we've got to bring
in the treatments for the chronic
diseases like diabetes and insulin and
so on and people have been displaced and
they've lost access to their regular
Health Services uh in part because of
that and partly because of damaged
Health Facilities so we're working to
address uh that issue there's a big
issue related to infectious diseases
I've mentioned the ongoing cholera
outbreak but now we've got new levels of
displacement and people overcrowded in
these Collective centers that are
unhygienic there's poor sanitation poor
water so we're working very closely with
our partners on ensuring that there is
better water and sanitation and
Infectious Disease Control across the
board but with a big Focus there and in
fact we have 1.7 million doses of oral
cholera vaccine on hand right now and
that we are we will be targeting those
most vulnerable communities at the end
of the first week of March so that's a
big priority for us mental health is
another major major priority so they're
the big issues that we're looking at
right now we will as fast as possible
and as soon as those resources arrive
the desperately needed resources arrive
we will shift gears into basic
Rehabilitation of Health Facilities as
well in the meantime we're working with
Partners to to run mobile clinics tent
clinics and and so on to extend those
basic basic Services
um perhaps you know in response to your
question about the diversion of Aid you
know adelhide and Mike have talked about
our long-term presence in in Northwest
Syria and indeed across the whole of
Syria uh we we bring in around 30 of of
the medicines and supplies into
Northwest Syria have done for a long
period of time uh we use third-party
monitoring to to determine how well
um those distributions occur and we're
very confident that prior to the
earthquake those distributions have met
all standards
um in terms of what's happened since the
earthquake of course you know it's you
know there's always a degree of chaos as
you distribute Aid following a major
acute emergency like this
um but yesterday I can tell you stories
I mean I I saw a man who'd been
discharged from hospital following
um a treatment of his fracture he had
what are called external fix fixators
metal you know scaffolding if you like
holding his bone together and and
patients like him need antibiotics he
was sitting in his Collective Center I
said what did the doctors give you
antibiotics he said yes and he pulled
them out of his pocket so the from the
visits that we took yesterday uh going
to Hospitals and Clinics asking if they
have enough medicines uh they they they
agreed that they did the doctor said
they had sufficient medicines what
they're lacking is the equipment uh that
we need the heavier equipment to to get
these hospitals fully functional so I'm
sorry that I've taken up a bit of time
there but I you know I hope I've been
able to convey the needs and the fact
that the distributions are going well
but we've got a lot more work to do
thank you so much Rick for a really
comprehensive answer that's great and I
guess with this we any way at the answer
of a briefing today
um
yeah let me remind everyone
um for the bureaucracy you'll see the uh
you'll get the the recordings right
after this briefing and the um
um the full transcript will be available
tomorrow during the day
um any follow-up questions please to
Media inquiries and back to Dr tatters
for closing
foreign
would like to probably add some some
points to that
as has been said
um
the syrians actually believe that the
earthquake is a lesser evil it's another
evil but a lesser evil compared to the
12 years of conflict
um but not only that the displacement
the economic meltdown of course copied
on top of that then then earthquake
anybody can see through watch what kind
of Hell the Syrian people are passing
um and maybe to share my surprise I was
in Munich and attended the Munich
security conference
last week and over the weekend
and many leaders have spoken
but
I haven't heard any mentioning the
crisis in in in Syria
and as Mike said I'm glad that the um
media is interested and bringing focus
into Syria because it really deserves
the attention of the International
Community but in International Security
meetings like Munich for leaders not to
mention about Syria means can tell tell
you a lot
um then
I hope the worrying part is
um will use this as opportunity because
whatever humanitarian supports who
provides or other humanitarian
agencies provide will not address the
problem
we may save lives but
the most important thing now is the
political solution
and that's why
um boring parties now we should use this
earthquake as opportunity to to talk to
each other and bring political uh
solution of course side by side we need
to do the humanitarian work
but I think a political solution is the
way uh forward and we hope peace will
come to this country
during our recent visit town after town
the level of distraction is unbelievable
I don't think there is any country that
has been destroyed to this level so I
hope the
Syrian leaders will take this as
opportunity to bring political solution
to this long-standing conflict that's
already that has already destroyed Syria
so from who side again we will do our
best and we have teams on on the ground
we will continue uh to do that and we
will continue to advocate for for Access
whether it's cross-border or crossline
every Syrian should be reached and and
and served and and supported during this
difficult times and we call on all
parties not only finding a political
solution but
not to politicize also the
humanitarian support and be ready to
give full access whether it's through
crossline or cross-border or other
mechanisms to save lives in Syria so
thank you
again for joining us to the press and
for raising I think many of the
questions were focused on Syria raising
this issue and see you next time
foreign
stopped
[Music]